hi there Steve company today I want to
continue talking a bit about teachers
because I made a blog post about why a
teacher can be so influential in our
language learning even though I feel
that to a large extent language learning
is dependent on the attitude of the
learner but many people aren't motivated
enough many people haven't yet been
turned on many people have inhibitions
many people probably the vast majority
of learners benefit from having the
right kind of teacher a teacher who
encourages them who stimulates them who
provides that human face-to-face contact
that makes them want to learn their
alpha we want to learn for the teacher
all of these many many reasons if the
teacher is the right kind of person a
good communicator warm with empathy
enthusiastic they can be absolutely
decisive a decisive element in the
success of the student and in that
regard I want to pay tribute to such a
teacher who might met when I was in
Saigon excuse me I'm in Hanoi
his name is mal Pritchard or Richard
he's an Australian a retired Australian
who lives in Hanoi and when we had our
meet up in Hanoi he came with a number
of other people he would let me pay for
my beer and whatever little munchies we
had a very generous warm gregarious type
of person and he in his retirement years
claiming that he can live more cheaply
in Vietnam than in Australia on his
pension and whatever retirement income
he has he is a volunteer teacher sort of
like the Pied Piper of Hamelin who
gathers Vietnamese students around him
in the center of old Hanoi and teaches
them English and it's a phenomenal story
in my mind of people communicating
across cultural divides as I remember he
speaks some
means I can't say how well he speaks
Vietnamese but he's totally comfortable
living in them happy being there
obviously gets a great sense of
satisfaction from the genuine good that
he is able to do and I think very often
we get more satisfaction in giving than
in receiving and his students are very
very happy and that mal is there for
them so I'm going to post in the
description and links to two videos one
which describes his program both of
these videos are done by mouths students
Oh mal and mitts are much more
proficient when it comes to technology
and such then mal is but I did mention
in my blog post which I might also put a
link to in my description
I mentioned that I mentioned Donald
Duffy this excellent Spanish teacher in
Delaware in the US I also mentioned
Moyes Hobbiton who was a great
inspiration to me and my French and then
in my subsequent interest in language
learning and so here is a bit of a
profile of mal Pritchard and I am sure
there are lots of these excellent
teachers out there and they have a major
impact on language learning success so
thank you for listening and this is for
mal I promise to do something like this
a lot earlier and with one thing in
another I never did but here we go
thank you for listening bye for now